i love you
[Music]
kylie jenner's three-year-old daughter
stormy webster
is here to make your day with a heavy
dose of over-the-top
cuteness she's the cool one on wednesday
the kylie cosmetics founder took to
instagram to share
this sweet clip lounging in bed with her
little girl watching
boss baby 2. and apparently stormy was
feeling the movie
and wasn't feeling the spotlight
[Applause]
okay two things to discuss stormy is
just straight up ignoring her mom
which i gotta say that's just standard
movie watching etiquette
stormy i feel you and two
goose how cute is that little nickname
i love it anyway stormy was like real
focused on the flick and couldn't be
bothered with her mama's i love yous
stormy fine i can prove that everything
i'm saying
oh yeah yeah i love you thank you
i love you i love you
storm ace i love you
[Music]
let's play that sweet little voice back
one more time
of course kylie and stormy are like two
peas in a pod
the mommy daughter duo had a fun time
celebrating the 4th of july on a family
getaway
the 23 year old shared this snap of her
little one playing with her cousin kim
kardashian's daughter
chicago and that that's stormy hanging
with her dad
travis scott and right here straight
ahead
last month the makeup mogul and the
rapper stepped out with their daughter
for the 72nd annual parsons benefit in
new york city
where the 30 year old musician was
honored
during his speech he gave a special
shout out to kylie and his daughter
saying quote stormy i love you and wifey
i love you yeah he called kylie his
wifey
amazing kylie later shared a few pics
from the quick getaway alongside the
caption
24 hours in nyc meanwhile stormy's
appearance on the red carpet
with her famous parents was the first
one since the premiere of travis scott
look mom i can fly
in 2019.
and just last month when it comes to
their relationship
a source told et that kylie and travis
are trying to make things work
quote travis really respects kylie and
worships the ground she walks on
she means a lot to him he loves that
kylie is such a boss and how great of a
mom she is
kylie loves that travis is so creative
and that he makes a big effort to be
involved in stormy's life
the source also noted that the pair
hopes to give stormi a sibling one day
kylie would love to have more kids one
day and she would of course love for the
father of her future children to be
travis
but they aren't putting any pressure on
themselves and are seeing where things
go
in the meantime kylie is busy with the
july 15th relaunch of kylie cosmetics
it's fun earlier this month the
entrepreneur announced that the brand is
going clean
with vegan formulas and updated
packaging
the company will also launch a new
direct to consumer website
where fans can shop both kylie cosmetics
and
kylie skin she works really hard she
made her own money
for over a decade she put it in the bank
she saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really
you know decided on what she wanted to
do she spent
her money on a venture that could have
gone south or north
and it did really well
you